on doit tous merci de nous retrouver sur
public sénat les temps sont durs pour le
gouvernement au sénat il faut dire que
depuis la semaine dernière les sénateurs
sont en train de réécrire complètement
le projet de loi de réforme de la
décentralisation
j'ai comme un sentiment de solitude a
déclaré hier en séance publique
marylise lebranchu la ministre de la
décentralisation constamment mise en
minorité depuis le début de l'examen de
ce texte
vendredi soir elle a assisté au rejet
des deux principales mesures de ce
projet de loi à savoir la création d'une
conférence territoriale assorti d'un
pacte de gouvernance territoriale et
hier coup de théâtre les sénateurs ont
supprimé les articles créant la
métropole de paris hier soir ils ont
entamé les articles créant la métropole
de lyon et les débats vous allez le voir
était un petit peu moins animé retour
donc ce matin sur la séance d'hier soir
bonne matinée à tous et nous en arrivons
à l'article 20 pour lequel j'ai une
demande de parole de madame kuperman
mais monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues depuis le
début de nos travaux en commission nous
avons beaucoup entendu parler de la
future métropole lyonnaise
comme si tout le monde se réjouissait de
la mise en place de cette nouvelle
collectivité
et comme si cela ne semblait poser de
problème à personne
il y a cependant il venait juste
d'arriver monsieur collomb vous et vous
avez raison il ya cependant un aspect
qui n'a jamais été soulevée
en effet cette métropole al'inverse des
autres n'est pas un établissement public
de coopération acquis les communes
délègue un certain nombre de leurs
compétences
il s'agit si la loi est votée d'une
collectivité de plein exercice qui
absorbent en fait l'essentiel des
compétences des communes
ainsi pour la première fois la loi
décide d'attribuer à une collectivité la
tutelle complète d'une collectivité sur
les autres en effet par définition les
communes ne sont pas membres de la
métropole la loi n'a toujours pas prévu
qu'une collectivité territoriale soit
composé par d'autres collectivités elles
sont censées être indépendantes les unes
des autres
aussi dans cette perspective
métropolitaine yonnaise comment
pourrons-nous toujours dire que toutes
les communes de ce territoire dispose de
leur libre administration dans les
domaines que la loi leur attribue en
fait les communes ne deviennent que des
arrondissements mais ne peuvent demeurer
des communes tant les pouvoirs qui lui
restent attachés sont faibles et de fait
leur autonomie financière et fiscale
réduite aux acquêts
finalement il n'est pas sûr que cette
création à les conditions de cette loi
soit parfaitement constitutionnel
la mise sous tutelle des communes de la
communauté urbaine de lyon actuel est
même clairement définies dans ce texte
et les attributs de leur libre
administration totalement remis en cause
la présentation avantageuse de
l'opération de métropolisation vise
évidemment à laisser penser que ce
mouvement est dans l'ordre des choses et
qu'un avenir radieux à temps les
habitants de la future métropole et ce
alors même que les mots qui traversent
la société française depuis la loi
créant les communautés urbaines depuis
1969 plus loin sont bien loin d'épargner
le grand lyon
1,2 million d'habitants sont concernés
certes oui mais bien des mauves ont
encore coulé sur le sujet comme cool la
saône et le rhône vers une confluence
dont l'avenir n'est pas temps n'est pas
encore tout à fait établi
les enjeux sont sérieux fin décembre
2011 on comptait sur le territoire du
grand lyon près de 95 mille chômeurs
dont le tiers de longue durée plus de
cinquante mille familles monoparentales
un revenu fiscal moyen supérieur à la
moyenne nationale mais plus de 40 % de
personnes non imposables disposant de
moins de 10000 euros de revenus
l'agglomération compte près de 30 zones
urbaines sensibles sur son territoire à
la grappinière commune de vaulx en velin
le revenu moyen est inférieur de 20% à
celui de la commune et ne représente que
45 % du revenu des habitants de
l'agglomération
plus largement près de 25 mille familles
de ces zones urbaines sensibles ont des
ressources constituées totalement ou
majoritairement de prestations
familiales sur le plateau des minguettes
cher à nos collègues guy fischer à
vénissieux le quart de la population la
plus modeste dipose ne dispose pas de
l'équivalent de 40% du revenu observé
sur l'agglomération
alors bien sûr il y à d'autres vos
quartiers beau d'autres beaux villages
il y a le mont-dore la tête d'or où les
bretons la métropole sans les dans la
métropole lyonnaise la métropole sans
les lyonnais ne sera qu'une construction
technocratique de plus éloigné de la
population et neuro pendant aucunement à
ses besoins ni à la nécessaire vitalité
démocratique qui doit accompagner chaque
grand projet structurant pour répondre
aux besoins de solidarité des femmes et
des hommes qui vivent sur ce territoire
au nom de la concurrence libre et non
faussée entre les territoires les
échelons démocratique vont être
sacrifiés sur l'autel de la finance
la métropole de fête couple territoire
en deux et ce sans aucune consultation
des populations
alors permettez moi mes chers collègues
à l'heure où le débat semble enfin
vouloir s'ouvrir sur la question du
cumul des mandats c'est pourtant
l'accumulation des pouvoirs dans les
mains de quelques-uns que certains que
cet article et les suivants entendent
inscrire dans la loi
c'est dans ce sens que nous voterons pas
cet article et nous demande
des suppressions sur l'ensemble des
articles qui concernent la création de
la métropole lyonnaise mais mon cher
collègue merci j'ai crû comprendre qu à
la fin sur quelques répartition
financière le grand accord de façade
n'était pas encore complètement réglé
entre vous mais je laisse le débat
s'installe et pour régler les dernières
pages les dernières problème de virgule
à l'euro près merci cher club la parole
est à monsieur mercier merci beaucoup
monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues
bon et bien évident que je ne partage
pas les sentiments que via d'exprimer
que german je crois au contraire ce
projet profondément nécessaire est
également un projet évidemment
démocratique contrairement à ce qu elles
viennent de dire je voudrais expliquer
sur ses deux bois nécessaire parce que
lyon et son agglomération constitue une
grande force humaine économique culturel
et qui mérite d'être individualisé et
qui mérite surtout cette grande force
humaine d'avoir tous les moyens de son
expansion
quand un territoire et prospère il n'est
jamais que pour lui même il l'est aussi
pour les autres pour ses voisins
lorsque lyon progressent tous les
territoires qui sont autour
en profite il y a des retombées et on ne
va pas construire un mur autour de lyon
la métropole que l'on veut bâtir et tous
les rôles qui est ouverte ouverte sur
ses plus proches voisins ouverte bien
sûr sur le monde entier après
et lorsque on a bien vu les difficultés
qu'il y a
à modifier les structures locales depuis
que nous sommes sur ce sujet nous avons
trouvé d'accord c'est vrai
je n'ai pas honte au contraire je suis
plutôt fier de l'accord qui doit plus
trouvé le sénateur maire de lyon et moi
même pour aller vers la construction de
cette métropole
pourquoi d'abord pour une raison toute
simple vous verrez on voit bien quand on
compare l'article 20 dans son premier
alinéa avec quelle les autres
dispositions concernant les autres
grandes métropoles
on peut exprimer en quelques mots ce
qu'est la métropole lyonnaise
c'est une collectivité territoriale de
la république un statut dérogatoire
certes mais une collectivité
territoriale de la république comme le
prévoit l'article 72 de la constitution
c'est pas un syndicat mixte pas
syndicats syndicats c'est pas une
d'assemblage de syndicats c'est une
collectivité territoriale
je crois que ça répond à une exigence
démocratique toute simple qui est aussi
le principe d'intelligibilité que doit
avoir une structure
on aurait pu bâtir un système où une
place pose département il place pour la
communauté urbaine place pour la région
une place pour tout le monde
non il faut sortir je crois profondément
qu'il faut sortir de cette logique
et quand on peut bâtir un accord il faut
aller dans l'air d'accord claire parce
que c'est ce que comprennent nos
concitoyens et ils pourront
naturellement juger si l'action qui est
menée leur plaît ou ne plaît pas quand
on est élu on a un seul m c'est le
suffrage universel n'a pas d'autre et
les électeurs pourront à intervalles
réguliers
c'est ça la démocratie veut dire dire
s'ils sont contents de gestion doivent
être peu ou pas il fallait une condition
il fallait qu'une condition soit remplie
pour cela il fallait qu'il n'y ait plus
département le sur le territoire de la
métropole
je vais pas dire et c'était pas pour moi
quelque chose de difficile que de dire
ça à titre personnel bien sûr que
j'étais attaché à cette institution
j'étais plus encore attaché au devenir
de lure a fait en sorte que vraiment
nous ayons une grande métropole et il y
a longtemps que j'ai pris cette position
je les ai rapporté un des rares à porter
que je remercie encore
un article du progrès de 2008 où je
mettais prononcé en faveur de cette fois
trop paul je disais pour qu'il y ait une
métropole faut qu'il n'y ait plus de
départements on peut pas avoir un
empilement de collectivités et oui sinon
il n'y a pas de métropole
voilà aujourd'hui nous arrivons à cela
et je crois que je crois très
profondément et je pense que ce modèle
que nous construisons à lyon c'est un
modèle pour lyon si d'autres sont
inspirés ils ne peuvent pas notre désir
c'est pas de le voir imposer à qui que
ce soit ben c'est pas il faut tenir
compte
il faut te dire b je sais bien que chers
collègues mirassou quai à toulouse ça
marcherait pas parce qu'elle est un
petit problème c'est qu'il faut montrer
qu'on aime ceux qui sont autour
et pas simplement les aspirer et des
spas et et à lyon c'est notre culture
oui mais je sais très bien ce que je dis
est à lyon notre culture notre culture
qui nous permet en ayant des positions
ne m'en partisans différend oppose et
c'est de savoir ce qui est essentiel et
qui peut nous rassemble et on le montre
en construit dans cette métropole voit
juste que je souhaite c'est que grâce à
cette métropole cette construction
institutionnelle
lyon et son agglomération soit demain
plus grand plus prospère plus fort plus
démocratique et je sais que si cela se
fait je sais que si cela ce fait les
territoires qui sont autour
et notamment de partir du rhône en
profitera en premier et que c'est ainsi
qu'on va faire les choses et puis si sur
un endroit dans notre pays on peut
montrer que les collectivités locales
peuvent bouger
ben c'est probablement un signe que
toutes les autres peuvent le faire pas
forcément le même jour mais que ça peut
venir un jour merci
merci chers collègues la parole est un
monsieur buffet
oui monsieur le président chers
collègues quelques mots on parle
beaucoup
régulièrement du fait urbain comme
l'événement de ces quarante dernières
années et je crois qu'effectivement sur
l'agglomération lyonnaise
il est la preuve vivante que 44 années
de communauté urbaine ont permis aux
élus de ce territoire de travailler
ensemble de faire évoluer ce territoire
de façon positive d'ailleurs quelles que
soient les élus qui ont été là depuis
ces longues années et qu au bout de 44
ans nous arrivons à un moment où nous
avons besoin de relever d'autres défis
un défi d'existence de cette métropole à
la fois dans les ti libre nationale mais
pas seulement un rôle important sur tout
l'arc sud-est européen où la métropole
lyonnaise a un rôle considérable à jouer
par ailleurs nous sommes d'accord pour
considérer depuis longtemps qu'une
évolution est donc nécessaire en 2010
nous avons été en tous les cas pour
notre majorité favorable au texte qui a
été présenté par le gouvernement et par
la création de ces métropoles
j'ai appelé de mes voeux à la communauté
urbaine de lyon que l'on puisse créer
celle ci choses nos passes se sont pas
faites dans ce sens là mais aujourd'hui
nous arrivons avec un texte qui est sans
doute le plat de substantiel de ce texte
de loi en la matière et c'est celui qui
apporte le plus une évolution et cette
évolution nous devons la prendre
elle n'est sans doute pas parfaite car
elle pose quelques difficultés mais les
difficultés ne valent pas la peine de
l'empêcher de pouvoir exister de pouvoir
se mettre en route
nous avons incontestablement un problème
de limites de cette métropole et de la
présence sur son territoire d'un grand
équipement qui fait métropole qui est
celui de l'aéroport de
lyon-saint-exupéry un amendement qui a
été déposée permet d'avancer sur le
sujet et c'est plutôt une bonne chose
nous avons un deuxième problème plutôt
un enjeu qu'il faut relever que j'aurais
dû dire qu'il était le premier
c'est celui selon lequel nous ne sommes
plus un ep c'est à partir du 1er janvier
nous serons une véritable collectivités
locales cette collectivité locale aura
besoin d'une élection au suffrage
universel direct
à l'horizon de 2020 c'est ce qui a été
annoncé
même le ministre il a été dit dans cet
hémicycle la semaine dernière qu'il
fallait d'ores et déjà travaillé sur le
mode électoral qui doit se mettre en
route
à cette date nous le devons aux élus
mais ce que nous devons oser lui aussi
c'est de discuter avec lui le devenir de
leur commune et les 58 mer les 58
collègues de la communauté urbaine ont
envie de savoir comment ils vont être
traités dans ce dispositif
certes les dispositions de la loi vont
permettre de fixer d'ores et déjà un
certain nombre d'enjeux
mais l'élection au suffrage universelle
de 2020 probablement procédera à une
nouvelle évolution qu'il faut savoir ne
pas cacher mais par contre anticipé et
expliquer ça c'est un enjeu extrêmement
important et puis enfin je crois que il
ya un dernier sujet sur lequel le
gouvernement doit avancer pour continuer
d'aller dans le bon sens c'est soit la
sphère des financements et la question
des financements du des croisements
entre le futur nouveau département du
rhône et la métropole lyonnaise
il ya une demande qui a été faite très
nettes par la commission des lois
il la semaine dernière nous avons besoin
aussi d'avancer sur ce sujet je suis
peut-être depuis longtemps je crois
pouvoir le dire et sans être contredit
par mes collègues de lyon ici le
partisan de l'évolution de notre
territoire
parce que nous avons des défis et des
enjeux à relever
certes un certain nombre d'entre nous
s'inquiète c'est ma foi normal il est
vrai que la force des habitudes
s'accommode mal de l'ivresse de l'action
mais nous allons devoir avancer et
procéder par étapes et expliquez moi je
pense que c'est un bel enjeu
même si à certains égards je le redis il
n'est pas complètement abouti mais la
métropole de lyon si elle peut servir
d'exemple pour d'autres
et bien c'est un point important nous
nous retrouvons sur ce sujet là avec le
sénateur maire de lyon moi je suis élu
des communes de l'agglomération
lyonnaise j'ai un certain moment occupé
des fonctions dans cette communauté
urbaine de dans l'exécutif pour
m'occuper notamment d'urbanisme et on a
bien senti très vite il y a déjà dix ans
la nécessité de cette évolution
alors nous allons franchir cette étape
il faut la franchir je pense avec
confiance mais nous avons besoin du
gouvernement rapidement pour clarifier
les points à la fois financier et les
points d'évolution à l'horizon de 2020
parce que nous ne sommes plus nous ne
serons plus 1,2 pc mais une collectivité
locale ce qui en réalité change tout
merci merci chers collègues je n'ai pas
d'autres demandes de monsieur collomb
bien chers collègues quelques mots pour
expliquer ce que nous avons essayé de
faire ce que je crois nous allons faire
si vous en êtes d'accord
tout d'abord dire quelques mots parce
que vu peut-être d'un peu loin
on a l'impression que l'agglomération
lyonnaise a toujours été une
agglomération riche et prospère
je rappelle mes chers collègues que lyon
fut une grande ville du textile moi je
fus élu dans un arrondissement à
l'époque qui avaient subi de plein fouet
la désindustrialisation
c'était l'arrondissement dans lesquels
se trouvaient une usine emblématique
rhodia c'est à 7500 salariés et tout
d'un coup
cette usine ferme et toutes les autres
industries de cet arrondissement avait
fermé c'était mon premier mon problème
premier et depuis j'ai gardé en mémoire
que si on voulait qu'une agglomération
puisse vivre qu'un arrondissement puisse
vivre
il fallait y apporter le développement
économique et donc chaque fois c'est
pour cela par exemple que pour nous
l'innovation est quelque chose de
capital comme compétence à inclure dans
les pouvoirs de la métropole
il faut sens
est-ce se projeter dans l'avenir si on
ne veut pas petit à petit perdre
totalement de sa substance et se
trouvait marginalisés dans le monde
économique et celui d'aujourd'hui
deuxième point qu'on oublie quelquefois
vous vous rappelez ici mais de manière
statique c'est que l'agglomération
lyonnaise fut celle qui connut à la
révolte des banlieues vénissieux et
vaulx-en-velin et peut-être y at-il un
peu de mauvaise foi dans vos propos mais
venez j'invite tous nos collègues
communistes à venir voir l'agglomération
lyonnaise et à venir voir en particulier
ce que nous faisons pour essayer de
réduire la fracture territoriale qui
pour moi est la pire des fractures
aujourd'hui nos fracture sociale sont
d'abord des fractures spatiale et venez
voir ce que nous avons fait à vaulx en
velin ce que nous avons fait à
vénissieux en l'espace de deux mandats
c'est dans ces communes que nous avons
concentré le maximum de nos moyens à la
fois installations de transport en
commun tramway à vénissieux métro plus
ce tram nous tramway à vaulx en velin
prolongation et d'une autre ligne forte
pour desservir le coeur de vaulx en
velin un effort considérable de t'être
340 millions d'euros au cours de ce
mandat sur vénissieux et environ 200
millions d'euros sur vaulx en velin
pardon et 200 millions d'euros sur
vénissieux oui nous avons ce souci là et
qu'est ce que nous voulons faire lorsque
nous proposons de réunir les compétences
de le pci du grand lyon avec le conseil
général va simplement faire en sorte que
nous puissions assurer une
complémentarité dans nos compétences
d'abord nous étions sur des compétences
qui étaient les mêmes
dans l'agglomération lyonnaise par
exemple il y avait des voiries qui était
départemental et d'autres qui étaient
communautaire ça marche mieux si a
qu'une personne qui contient un
carrefour fait toutes les voiries et
d'accès aux carrefours plutôt que si on
est deux avec des normes techniques
différentes avec des points de vue
différents sur la façon dont il faut
bâtir ces voiries
ensuite nous avons un certain nombre de
compétences qui sont complémentaires
voyez par exemple nous au grand lyon
nous sommes plutôt aujourd'hui mais à
part le développement économique dont
j'ai parlé dans l'urbanisme et le
logement
nous construisons beaucoup de logements
on le disait tout au long de ses ébats
dix mille logements par an chez qui pour
un million cinq cent mille habitants 400
mille quatre cent soixante mille et
évidemment tout à fait important mais
dans ces logements
c'est le conseil général qui s'occupe
évidemment du rsa des politique du
handicap des politiques des personnes
âgées et non que pouvoir réunir ses
compétences à la fois de construction
mais en même temps de gestion des
destinées personnelles
c'est à mon avis profondément
complémentaires et cela nous permettra
de mieux prendre en compte les destinées
de celles et ceux à qui vous faisait
référence tout à l'heure oui il y à un
certain nombre de difficultés
oui dans cette agglomération comme dans
toutes les agglomérations particulier
dans la période que nous vivons il y a
effectivement des personnes qui sont en
marge de la société
mais justement c'est pour nous donner
des atouts supplémentaires pour les
réinsérer dans le mouvement social dans
la dynamique sociale d'ensemble que nous
faisons cette métropole et que nous
bâtissons cette collectivité d'intérêt
particulier le faisons nous contre nos
communes non et vous le savez bien vous
qui êtes en commission des lois
j'ai déposé un certain nombre
d'amendements que nous verrons tout à
l'heure pour faire en sorte que
là où il pouvait y avoir des ambiguïtés
des interrogations on puisse
effectivement montré que les communes
restent effectivement maîtresse pas
simplement de compétences mineurs pas
simplement de l'état civil comme
quelquefois on a pu le dire de danse et
des bas mais reste des communes de plein
exercice
moi je suis maire de lyon je veux pas
transférer mes compétences à la
métropole
je veux effectivement qu'il y à une
harmonisation
mais que chacun reste avec des
compétences bien établie voilà ce que
nous voulons faire l'an après est-ce que
nous avons bafouer la démocratie voyez
bien déjà que sur les discours sur ses
rangs nous avons essayé de construire un
consensus
rien encore des questions qui se posent
on a quelquefois poser la question du
suffrage universel et la commission des
lois cet après midi à discuter d'un
projet d'amendement sur lesquelles le
président et le rapporteur s'explique on
mais ne mélangeons pas les débats allons
par étapes
ou alors ce sera comme le vote qui a été
émis tout à l'heure on voudra courir 10e
à la fois et finalement on en attrape a
aucun alors mes chers collègues
voilà ce que nous voulons faire ce que
nous aurons l'occasion d'expliquer tout
au long de ces débats sur l'article 20
et la métropole lyonnaise et nous
essayons de le faire
en recherchant le maximum de consensus
parce que il y à des débats qui
dépassent nos personnes qui sont
essentiels pour le devenir
pas simplement de notre agglomération
mais je crois de la france je vous
invite à lire un très très beau livre de
monsieur laurent davezies s'appelle la
crise qui vient
il montre qu aujourd'hui très largement
l'économie productive repose sur un
nombre assez limité des rues urbaines et
qu'à partir de cette économie productive
passé paraît certain nombre de
géographes en tout cas le pense il y a
ensuite une possibilité de construction
économie résidentielle mais monsieur
collombat je vous invite à ce que nous
en débattions ensemble dans un autre
lieu peut-être qu'ici parce que le débat
mérite à feu du temps je reconnais que
je voulais vous dire en introduction à
cet article 20 merci la parole et est un
monsieur le rapporteur vingtaine
d'hommes comme beaucoup ici
après quelques heures de vol deux
témoignages quand même d'un élu du nord
sur ce que je pu observer sur lyon
première chose que fait il ya une
quinzaine d'années un des tout premiers
mipim la métropole lilloise
venez avec pour présenter son urbanisme
commercial les roubaix tourcoing
villeneuve-d'ascq sur le stand plus loin
de lyon il y avait 1
le vice-président charrier maire de
vaulx en velin qui présentait
l'urbanisme commercial dans ce nom dans
sa globalité et qui avec beaucoup de
clarté montrer voilà la stratégie des
communes et de la communauté urbaine
c'est d'arrêter
l'extension des centres commerciaux
périphériques c'est de choisir de
conforter
ces pôles de développement qui était
articulée avec déjà à l'époque le une
logique de renouvellement urbain
je veux quand même le dire premier
souvenir deuxième souvenir pour ce il ya
quand même quelques pointures ici ceux
qui s'intéressent à la politique de la
ville il n'est pas contesté il n'est pas
contesté mais tout le monde a des
pointures bien sûr chaque chaussure une
profonde il n'est pas contesté ici que
l'intégration des préoccupations du
développement social des quartiers dans
les dimensions des politiques d'habitat
a été faite aussi en avance sur d'autres
pas mieux que d'autres mais en avance
sur d'autres du côté de lyon une
métropole voyez vous c'est me
semble-t-il
d'abord ça c'est à dire deux forces qui
se conjuguent qui conflue excusez moi ça
s'invente pas une force de cohésion
sociale et et d'habitat une force de
développement économique intégré si vous
comparez à marchais qui a ses atouts est
incontestablement convenait quand même
que vous n'avez pas en terme d'échelle
de développement à la grande surface
vous n'avez pas la même logique de
développement intégré territoriale est
encore une fois sans préjuger des atouts
des villes concernées
donc moi je voudrais vraiment témoigner
que quand j'ai dit dans la discussion
générale
hazard calligraphique que c'est le seul
endroit où la métropole dans le texte
avait une majuscule c'est parce
qu'effectivement elle la mairie ce qui
ne veut pas dire que j'idéalise mais ce
que je veux dire c'est qu'effectivement
il y à là en marche une véritable
dynamique métropolitaine dont les
chiffres
mon qu'elle produise ses effets bien au
delà du terrain du périmètre concerné
par l'opération entre guillemets c'est à
dire le périmètre de la communauté
urbaine de lyon actuel y a qu'à regarder
le nombre à si vous regardez les
mouvements entrants sortants
regardez la part d'emplois à lyon
territoire communautaire
que représente par exemple pour le reste
de la région dépasse même le département
je crois que c'est tout à fait hors dons
cette dimension là qui n'est pas
exclusif de la proximité de la
participation des habitants mais qui
donne à la politique notamment au à la
politique de la ville cette cohérence
lyon l'a montré avant d'autres c'est mon
seul témoignage le témoignage que je
veux dire c'est que quand même la
maturité des élus de bords différents
capables sur l'essentiel de s'entendre
et ça je voulais le saluer parce que a
de la chance un territoire
quand il a ça dans ces ingrédients merci
monsieur bourdin monsieur le président
de la commission des lois
monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues
c'est avec beaucoup d'humilité que
j'interviens après eux michel mercier
gérard collomb françois noël buffet et
les collègues qui connaissent au premier
chef
ce qui se passe à lyon et qui ont
tellement d'oeuvrer pour que l'on soit
aujourd'hui ce soir avec ce projet mais
si je tiens à intervenir
c'est parce que la commission des lois a
apporté son soutien à votre projet et
puis c'est parce que il me paraît très
important de réfléchir en cette
circonstance
à la manière dont change les choses dans
notre pays
comment il ya t'il du changement social
du changement territoriales il y à des
conceptions bien connu et certains
pensent que l'organisation territoriale
doit être du modèle de la langue pour
barrère où l'abbé grégoire sous la
révolution française qui disait la
langue d'un peuple libre doit être une
est la même pour tous et on a longtemps
pensé que toute l'organisation
territoriale devaient être une est la
même pour tous et que ce jacobinisme
souvent exacerbé était la voie du
progrès et il a été la voie du progrès
parce que la république est fondée sur
le principe d'égalité mais le principe
d'égalité et je crois compatible avec le
droit l'initiative et avec la pluralité
et la diversité
voyez-vous lorsque et rené van dirais
donc là rappelle le rappelle souvent il
fut décidé en 1966 par les pouvoirs
publics d'alors le gouvernement d'alors
le président de la république d'alors de
créer des communautés urbaines
que n'at-on pas entendu on nous a dit
c'est la mort des communes
lorsqu il y a eu les lois de
décentralisation ce n'était pas des
collègues communistes mais tes collègues
de droite qui à l'assemblée nationale
par les perpétuellement de ce danger
extraordinaire pour la france non je
regarde les chaises vides boscher
collègues lorsque il y a eu en 92
la création des communautés de communes
on nous a dit c'est la mort des communes
aujourd'hui les communautés de communes
sont partout et je n'oublie pas que la
seconde comme
notez de communes fut créé en france par
françois patriat les communautés de
communes sont partout et les communes
sont toujours là alors qu'à cette
tribune il y avait eu des dizaines
d'interventions pour dire le contraire
quand on a créé les communautés de ville
elles n'ont pas eu de succès parce qu'il
a fallu du temps et il a fallu que dans
la ville de rennes je l' ai déjà dit il
a fallu il a fallu attendre sept ans
mais il a fallu que dans la ville de
rennes on expérimente pour la première
fois en france la taxe professionnelle
unique d'agglomération
personne ne faisait ça messin servi à
tout le monde
et lorsque les communautés
d'agglomérations sont arrivés on nous a
dit c'est la mort des communes
il y à des communautés d'agglomération
dans beaucoup d'endroits et les communes
sont toujours là alors j'invite madame
cécile cukierman eux qui a parlé avec
beaucoup de conviction je me permets de
dans le dialogue démocratique de dire
mais est ce que c'est vrai ce discours
selon lequel les communes vont
disparaître est ce que au contraire le
chemin du progrès n'est pas la bonne
dialectique entre une bonne organisation
au niveau de l'ère urbaine réel et bien
entendu la nécessaire commune de
proximité que tous les français ont dans
leur coeur et à laquelle nous tenons
plus que tout mais est-ce
contradictoires ou est-ce
complémentaires moi je crois que c'est
complémentaire et je crois aussi que
pour que les choses changent il faut des
lois
nous sommes là pour cela pour que les
choses changent il faut des initiatives
lorsque en bretagne il a été décidé de
faire une conférence souples légères
utile et efficace entre 16 personnes
c'était bien et cela nous a inspirés
encore aujourd'hui madame la ministre
et nous devons rendre cet hommage à la
bretagne
en alsace il ya eu un débat ce débat
a pas abouti mais peut-être qu'il
aboutira une autre fois et s'ils avaient
abouti
peut-être que cela aurait donné des
idées à d'autres
il aboutit négativement mais c'est la
démocratie
certains pensent que c'est très bien
qu'il y ait une haute normandie et une
basse normandie bien ils ont le droit de
le penser
on peut aussi penser que les limites des
régions ne sont pas quelque chose
d'intangible et qu' il ne faut pas que
partout ce soit toujours la même chose
voilà et bien moi je dis on verra on
fera le bilan
mais je suis persuadé que si le sénat
adopte et si le parlement adopte cette
proposition faite par michel mercier par
gérard collomb est partout leurs
collègues parce que s'il était tout seul
chacun dans leurs goûts dans leur
conseil général ou dans leur communauté
je ne pense pas qu'ils auraient pu
mettre cela en oeuvre et c'est pourquoi
ai je voulais conclure madame la
ministre mesdames les ministres mais non
mais je voulais conclure
écoutez je vois que vous attendiez avec
impatience la conclusion mais vous avez
raison monsieur y est c'est trop long il
vaut mieux le dire carrément puisque
vous le pensez un peu mais moi aussi je
le pense mais vous savez que j'aime bien
gramsci j'aime bien gramsci mais gelé
dans la tête et de même que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure contre la commune et les
agglomérations il y avait la dialectique
qui permet d'avancer
moi je vais vous dire que la loi moderne
la nouvelle idée de la loi qu'on
pourrait inventer ensemble c'est quand
la loi ne propose pas seulement
l'uniformité mais intègre mesdames les
ministres les initiatives qui sont
prises afin de les faire entrer dans la
loi de telle manière que la loi permet
est aux initiatives de fleurir dans leur
diversité
c'est une conception moderne et comme
c'est moderne
je vais féliciter également et ce sera
le mot de la fin
madame lebranchu madame escoffier merci
merci monsieur le président c'est
peut-être juste avant que vous puissiez
intervenir j'ai une dernière demande de
parole je passe donc la parole à
monsieur collombat n'ont cherché je
crois qu'à vouloir trop prouver on
trouve rien du tout le problème dès que
posent les métropoles n'est pas pour les
communes qui appartiennent à la
métropole qui décide de faire une
métropole une forme particulièrement
intégré de l'intercommunalité et qui
effectivement quand la barque est bien
mené profite aux communes qui sont les
mois les moins favorisés le problème
c'est les autres
c'est ceux qui sont à l'extérieur la
métropole alors en particulier quand la
métropole capte je disais souvent
vampirise les compétences des
départements voire voir des rayons et
l'exemple de de lyon moi me paraît le
plus satisfaisant dans la mesure où il
ya un partage finalement lyon sera le
même modèle que paris qui intègrent donc
des compétences du deccan compétences du
département et des dépenses et des
pardons et des compétences communales
bon cccc l'exemple qui ce qui pour moi
ça se discute le le moins c'est pour ça
que je je le
je le voterai sans état d'âme mais les
autres et en particulier et on le voit
bien
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir je
voulais pas intervenir ceux là dessus
parce que c'est là pour ma démonstration
c'est le moins bon exemple lyon tous les
autres on sait très bien que à la
périphérie ces réfugiés toute une partie
de la population qui a quitté
progressivement au fil des décades la
métropole qui vient travailler
effectivement au qui résident à
l'extérieur et qui vote de façon parfois
étonnantes
c'est ces gens qui posent problème et le
problème de la multiplication des
métropoles si on les multiplie ses
commun on va répondre à la paupérisation
extensive de ces territoires
c'est ça le problème des métropoles
alors non mais me dis que j'ai tort
j'attends j'attends et ya ce
probablement des moyens il ya
probablement des moyens dit d'y remédier
mais encore faut-il ce que je n'ai pas
vu dans en tout cas dans cette partie du
projet de problèmes de péréquation
comment organiser les réseaux enfin et
c'est bon mais tout ça on reste sur sa
faim
et plus on multipliera les métropole
dans les départements sans prendre un
minimum de précautions
plus on aura des problèmes il est là le
problème pour moi merci chers collègues
madame la ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je voudrais
simplement reprendre les propos de la
discussion générale qui a été ouverte
par madame lebranchu et qui dans ce
débat redonner quelques grands principes
clarification simplification maîtrise
des dépenses mais n'oubliez pas de dire
unités mais diversité faire en sorte que
ce texte puisse dans tous les cas
prendre en compte la diversité de notre
territoire et je crois que nous avons
avec le modèle lyonnais on va utiliser
le mot avec le modèle lyonnais
un modèle qui sans être abouti et je
reprends le qualificatif dippach par
monsieur buffet sans être abouti est un
modèle
qui aujourd'hui déjà a fait la preuve et
vous l'avez dit les uns et les autres
depuis 2008
il ya un travail qui a été fait entre
les élus de la communauté urbaine de
lyon entre le département pour faire
avancer pour permettre effectivement
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur collomb
que la la zone urbaine de lyon qui a
vécu des vrai traumatisme au plan
industriel a compris ce qu'était
l'importance de l'économie
et puis ce sur ce principe là essayer
d'élaborer quelque chose de constructif
alors oui c'est un projet qui certes
mérite d'être révisés et je comprends
madame kirmann ans vous ayant entendu
vos inquiétudes
simplement je crois que les uns et les
autres pendant ce débat nous essaierons
de les lever de faire entendre que les
solutions qui vont être mises en oeuvre
sont là pour apporter justement des
réponses concrètes
un dispositif qui ne manquera pas
d'évoluer avec le temps je voudrais
saluer tout particulièrement le travail
qui a été fait par la commission des
lois qui a bien pris en compte les
objectifs tels qu'ils étaient proposés
qui a bien mesurer les difficultés
auxquelles se trouvait confrontée et
heurté mais et vous l'avez dit monsieur
le rapporteur
il y avait cette maturité des élus qui
pour nous aujourd'hui sont un signe de
confiance qui vont nous permettre
d'avancer de façon à ce que ensemble
nous essayons de construire les
solutions les plus appropriées
alors j'ai bien retenu deux
problématiques deux problématiques sur
lesquelles le gouvernement en
particulier va s'engager à travailler
avec vous avec vous tous que vous soyez
de lyon que vous soyez du département
pour essayer tant sur le mode électoral
d'une part que sur les modalités de
financement que nous puissions aller un
peu plus loin parce que ce soir et dans
l'est dans les heures qui vont venir au
cours de ce débat il y a des
propositions qui vont être faites mais
des propositions sur lesquelles monsieur
le rapporteur nous n'avons pas pu les
uns et les autres
travailler suffisamment en profondeur
pour apporter des réponses qui seraient
des réponses sur et qui nous permettrait
assurément ce soir ou demain de dire eh
bien nous pouvons y aller mais c'est un
travail et sur lequel je sais le maire
de lyon et vous monsieur le président
vous avez choisi de travailler ensemble
nous serons à vos côtés
avec nos services pour essayer encore
une fois la d'apporter les solutions les
plus les plus importantes
je voulais vous dire vraiment à ce
moment là de ce débat la confiance que
nous faisons d'une part au travail que
vous nous avez présenté qui est celui du
résultat de plusieurs années de
confluence pour reprendre le mot qui a
été dit tout à l'heure un joli mot ce
travail de confluence entre vous tous
mais en même temps ça lui est vraiment
le travail qui a été fait un travail de
raison de réflexion de la commission des
lois à laquelle le gouvernement apporte
réellement là tous ces encouragements
tout son soutien et il essaiera vraiment
d'accompagner de la meilleures
conditions possibles l'ensemble de ce
débat en étant très vigilant et je veux
leur dire vraiment à nos amis ici aussi
sur les bancs en étant très vigilante
aux craintes qui sont les vôtres pour
essayer de les lever
voilà monsieur le président ce que je
voulais peut-être dire au nom du
gouvernement en a avant que ne commence
ce débat estimé le ministre
l'amendement 487 il est présenté par
madame plusieurs mois oui monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs mes
chers collègues je crois qu'il est
important vu de ce que je viens
d'entendre de rappeler quelques
préalables
tout d'abord ce n'est pas la revanche
d'un derby footballistiques qui se joue
ici entre madame cukierman gérard
collomb michel mercier les amendements
que nous avons travaillé avec mon groupe
sont des amendements qui ont été
travaillés en lien avec le président du
groupe communiste du grand lyon en lien
avec notre collègue sénateur guy fischer
et donc je j'entends tout ce qui se dit
mais ce n'est pas simplement des posture
dogmatique de
principe qui voudraient que nous ayons
poser ces amendements mais qui sont
aussi des amendements travailler avec
les élus locaux et qui effectivement je
crois que ça a été dit pour certains se
retrouvent pleinement partiellement dans
un projet qui n'est pas abouti et qui
donc pose débat
deuxièmement il y aurait pas ici les
ringards et partout ailleurs les
visionnaires de ce que doit être
l'avenir territoriale de notre pays
il n'y a pas d'un côté les ringards arc
bouté sur la défense de la commune quand
d'autres vers l avenir du pays comme
même pas d'ailleurs les gens le voient
parce que excusez moi mais la priorité
quand même des gens aujourd'hui dans
leur quotidien ce n'est pas la question
même de savoir si les communes doivent
rester commune ou si la métropole doit
être métropole leurs problèmes et terre
donc je crois qu'il faut être avec
beaucoup de modestie et ce n'est pas un
communiste qui a dit à propos de la
métropole lyonnaise qu'elle se voit
attribuer de plein droit de nouvelles
compétences sans clé mère est été
concertés c'est jean paul bret
ce n'est pas un communiste qui a dit que
dans ce texte la métropole de lyon sera
appelée à aspirer les compétences
communales c'est monsieur michel mercier
donc oui je crois que la question de la
place des communes dans la création de
cette nouvelle collectivité territoriale
que devient la métropole de lyon est un
problème qui semble être posée de façon
transversale et sur lequel on ne peut
pas simplement balayé d'un revers de
manche il n'y aurait pas non plus ici
les jacobins d'un ancien ordre face à
ceux qui auraient tous décentralisée
parce que rappelons aussi que le
problème du centralisme c'est le
centralisme napoléonien et que oui je
suis fier d'aider jacobine si c'est le
combat contre l'ancien régime et contre
les inégalités entre celles qui que
celles et ceux qui allaient devenir
citoyens citoyennes de notre république
donc je crois qu'il faut que nous
fassions très attention et que nous
n'ayons pas de faux débats etc cette
métropole
la seule question que nous posons c'est
qu'effectivement ce projet est lourd de
conséquences et je n'y a pas de propos
péjoratifs négatif ou positif
il est lourd de conséquences parce que
vous l'avez vous-même di meco et mes
chers collègues
c'est un acte important qu'ils créent
nouvelle organisation territoriale une
nouvelle collectivité territoriale mais
si le projet très bon soumettez le à
référendum
n'hésitez pas poser le ce débat là il
sera certainement nu et arrêter de
croire comme je l'aï déjà dit la semaine
dernière que quand nous posons cette
question là c'est simplement pour
sanctionner de façon négative parce
qu'effectivement on a tous les meilleurs
projets quand on est élu mais le jour où
les élus décideurs comme meilleur projet
de ne plus présenter aux et de ne plus
faire d'élection je crois que ça sera
quand même un mauvais projet qu'il nous
faudra dénoncer alors j'en finirai juste
et savoureux je reprendrai plus la
parole en explications de vote sur cet
amendement mais nous sommes dans cette
logique là nous la défendrons
effectivement jusqu'au bout et je tiens
à vous rappeler mon cher collègue gérard
collomb que vous
j'entends tout ce que vous dites et
personne ne juge le travail qui a été
fait sur la métropole lyonnaise
les élus communistes sont présents dans
l'agglomération de lyon et nous n'avons
pas attendu votre invitation
je fais partie de celles qui comptent le
conseil régional ont défendu la création
du pôle métropolitain lyonnais donc je
crois que ne nous faisons pas de faux
procès entre nous personne ne l'a jugé
ce qui se fait ou ne se fait pas en
matière de politique de logement ou
d'autres sur la courly actuellement et
demain sur la métropole lyonnaise mais
nous sommes là aujourd'hui pour décider
parce que vous l'avez dit monsieur
buffet l'exemple qui est en cours
aujourd'hui à lyon en appelle d'autres
et vous l'avez dit monsieur collomb bas
il y à ce qui se passe dans la métropole
milhas qui se passe à l'extérieur et
nous sommes sénatrices et sénateurs de
la république française merci chers
collègues
monsieur rapporteur quel avis de la
commission les gens ils attendent de
l'emploi et un logement à paris à lyon à
marseille et ailleurs est ailleurs
la dynamique métropolitaine contribue
précisément à la croissance et la
cohésion sociale des métropoles
contribuer à la mixité sociale c'est à
dire on peut laisser espérer que la
croissance sera demain plus inclusive
qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui
donc moi je le dise clairement
aujourd'hui la croissance en europe se
fait dans la construction métropolitaine
que je ne nie d alice pas comme un
modèle de compétitivité européenne que
j'essaie d'équilibrer dans la vision de
ces deux forces que sont cohésion
sociale logement
et puis croissance recherche innovation
et création d'emplois en ce sens là je
pense que on ne peut qu'être favorable
au texte tel qu'il est proposé est donc
j'émets un avis défavorable sur la
proposition même si je respecte au plus
haut point ses convictions de ma
collègue madame qui ferment si
l'inventeur madame la ministre
quel est l'avis du gouvernement l'avis
du gouvernement sera défavorable à cet
amendement pour en reprenant les
arguments qui viennent d'être dit mais
surtout en indiquant que la réforme qui
est proposée elle elle intègre l elle
s'inscrit vraiment dans le cadre de
cette évolution qui aujourd'hui et
sociales économiques environnementales
et qui donne du sens à une
à un ensemble urbain qui reste on l'a
dit tout à l'heure aussi je crois que
c'est un poids important près du citoyen
après du citoyen même si aujourd'hui on
utilise le mot de métropole c'est la
commune qui reste quand même le lieu où
le citoyen va se retrouver mais on donne
un sens global et cohérent
un ensemble urbain assumer la même
ministre
pour explication de vote pas
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement va
bien levé la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre veut bien levé la main
l'amendement n'est pas adoptée sur le
488 il est défendu pas de demandes
d'explications de vote même vote même
bottes un moment 489 même chose même
vote même vote le 2 151 rectifié tombe
le 697 et présenté par l'adami pièces à
hay
je vais être en opposition avec cet
hémicycle mais ces parages je recommence
à dire que je les dix ans lors de la
discussion générale que la démocratie
c'est tout de suite et que ce n'est pas
parce que en 2014 on aura un fléchage
des sur les listes municipales des
conseillers municipaux même sur une
liste de même inscrit sur un deuxième
partie du bulletin qui seront élus pour
représenter les communes à au conseil de
métropole que c'est de la démocratie ce
qui la vraie démocratie directe
aujourd'hui c'est d'effectivement avoir
le plus vite possible une discussion
commune un projet de métropole commun et
que ce soit pas des élus communaux qui
viennent représenter les communes et que
ce soit des élus métropolitains qui
viennent discuter de la métropole au
sein du conseil métropolitain
c'est déjà la première éléments qui nous
paraît
fondamentaux pardon fondamentale aux
yeux des écologistes le deuxième élément
c'est que pourquoi attendre 2020
pourquoi ne pas le faire dès 2014 dès
2014 nous et nous aimerions ainsi des
conseillers métropolitain qui
n'entrerait en fonction que lorsque la
métropole de lyon existerait réellement
mais au moins nous n'aurions pas pendant
six ans un dodge qui n'a aucun
légitimité autre que le fait qu'un jour
il a été le maire de lyon et qu'un jour
effectivement il a eu et il apporte et
je lui en fais et je lui en donne acte
et je le félicite pour ça qu'il a porté
avec son collègue du département du
rhône
le projet de métropole de lyon c'est
pourquoi il nous paraît essentiel aux
écologistes d'avoir dès aujourd'hui afin
dé 2014
une élection à part pour cette
collectivité territoriale de plein
exercice avec énormément de pouvoir et
donc j'ai déposé cet amendement et je
rappelle simplement que le sacre du doj
n'est jamais bien loin du pont des
soupirs
merci merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission sans polémique
je trouve que le fléchage va introduire
pour la première fois depuis longtemps
dans certes dont beaucoup d'endroits un
débat sur les enjeux intercommunaux et
je trouve que c'est déjà en soi un
progrès et que pour le reste je préfère
m'en tenir là émettre un avis
défavorable
à la proposition de ma collègue merci
sur un porteur madame ministre
quel est l'avis du gouvernement merci
monsieur le président le projet du
gouvernement et j'allais dire de sagesse
de maintenir pour le moment le mode
d'élection tel qu'il est et tel qu'il
existe il n'est pas utile c'est un point
que nous allons d'ailleurs débattre et
retravailler ensemble de façon à ce que
après 2015 et nous puissions trouver le
système qui sera le plus adéquat mais
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il nous faut
rester au système actuel sans aller vers
d'autres dispositions donc c'est un avis
défavorable 6 merci madame la ministre
l'explication de vote monsieur d'allier
merci monsieur le président je veux dire
les pièces que je partage son intention
parce que dans mon rapport de 2008
je propose est d'arriver à cette étape
là effectivement que la métropole du
grand paris à terme et dans un deuxième
temps effectivement soit composée d'élus
métropolitain élu sur un projet
politique et que les citoyens puissent
clairement choisir une option plutôt
qu'une autre
mais c'est vrai que c'est allé très loin
et j'avais même proposé l'étape
ultérieure encore l'élection du
président du grand paris au suffrage
universel donc non parlons pas c'était
pour 2020 ou 2030 peut-être on sera nous
serons à la retraite mais ceci étant dit
les pièces je partage le les intentions
qui sont les vôtres
ceci étant dit je pense pour une fois
peut-être que là il ne faut pas aller
trop vite
et effectivement adopté le système qui
nous est proposé merci chers collègues
je n'ai pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement veut
bien levé la main merci avis contraire
l'amendement n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 752 madame lipietz
la loi propose que ou impose que le nom
de cette collectivité territoriale
nouvelle et unique c'est intitule
métropole de lyon métropole avec un m
majuscule
alors que au même titre qu'on va dire
que la commune de paris lorsque m mais
une majuscule la commune de paris c'est
un événement historique et bien nous
avons là un événement historique qui
s'appelle la métropole de l'uo mais dans
les discussions où il est bien que à
plusieurs reprises depuis que nous avons
commencé à parler de cette partie du
texte
nous entendons métropole lyonnaise
métropole lyonnaise à deux reprises et
donc c'est bien parce que il y a un
problème de sémantique que je propose
que ce soit le conseil metropolit a donc
là l'ensemble des élus de la métropole
de lyon qui décide du nom de la
métropole qui pourra être lue aux
métropoles ou lyon paul où nathan de
lequel non au moins nous aurions un
début de véritable démocratie pour le
choix du nom ça me paraît extrêmement
important merci cher collègue monsieur
le rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission
mais faire observer
monsieur le président à un mac collègues
que l'article 20 institue une nouvelle
collectivité territoriale
le législateur en fixe le nom comme il y
a déjà procédé pour toutes les
collectivités qui ont été ainsi désigné
après ces régimes du code général des
collectivités territoriales qui prévoit
le cas échéant la procédure de
changement de nom d'une collectivité
mais quand même à la demande de cette
collectivité de grâce et par décret en
conseil d'état
voilà un sujet important madame le
ministre l'avis du gouvernement oui
l'avis du gouvernement
madame lipietz eux seraient et de
retirer votre amendement si vous le
vouliez bien parce que effectivement il
est de règle que c'est la loi qui fixe
le nom de la collectivité d'une
collectivité territoriale nouvelles de
plein exercice tout comme ça avait été
fait pour paris voir pour le départ des
départements comme le département de
mayotte
donc ne nous retrouvons vraiment
vraiment dans le prolongement du droit
du droit acquis merci madame la ministre
madame pièce vous ne retirez pas alors
il est retiré nous en nous enchaînons
sur le 698 je repasse la parole madame
lipietz pardon excusez moi cet
amendement est retirée ainsi que le
suivant j'ai oublié de faire tirer
excusez moi je 9 très bien nous en
arrivons 700 madani viêt nous enchaînons
allait retirer également très bien alors
nous avions trois amendements qui
faisait l'objet d'une discussion commune
le cese rectifié terre est retiré et
donc nous abordons successivement le 490
et le 491 ont tout d'abord le 490 ils
sont défendus
merci monsieur le rapporteur quel est
l'avis de la commission
cet amendement rend obligatoire la
consultation des conférences
territoriales lors de l'élaboration et
de la mise en oeuvre des politiques
métropolitaine
la généralité du champ de la
consultation que ces conférences telles
que prévues par l'article 20 induit la
faculté et non l'obligation de
conseiller les conférences elles seront
réunies à chaque étape importante de la
construction et de la mise en oeuvre du
projet métropolitain
donc elle ne saurait l'être quotidien
sauf à ralentir et alourdir la gestion
de la métropole ce et qui pourrait
ce qui pourrait être induits notamment
parfaite amendement raison pour laquelle
nous émettons au nom de la commission
des lois un avis défavorable à porter
madame la ministre l'avis du
gouvernement il elle est défavorable ou
à défaut de retrait parce que
effectivement aujourd'hui les
conférences territoriales des maires
sont des organes consultatifs qui ne
rendent que des avis 1 et n engagent ni
la métropole ni les communes et elles ne
sont pas de nature a nécessité un
contrôle étroit donc dans ces conditions
là voilà une disposition qui peut être
semble-t-il totalement retiré sinon avis
défavorable monsieur le président merci
madame la ministre nous sommes sur le
490 je n'ai pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veuille bien levé la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre va
bien levé la main l'amendement n'est pas
adoptée sur le 491 il est défendu
monsieur le rapporteur quel est l'avis
de la commission cet amendement apparaît
inutile s'agissant d'une instance
consultative en tout état de cause les
organes délibérants des communes comme
de la métropole pourront toujours
demander la formation si elles le
souhaitent
ce raison pour laquelle la commission
des lois a émis un avis défavorable sur
un tour mais le ministre l'avis est
favorable mais ma vie pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement veut
bien levé la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre va bien levé la main
l'amendement n'est pas adopté nous
arrivons à l'amendement 867 il est
présenté par monsieur le rapporteur au
nom de la commission des lois est
essentiellement de préciser que la
conférence métropolitaine se réunit à
l'initiative des maires pour examiner
les questions dont ceux ci veulent
débattre en son sein le mna ministre
quel est l'avis du gouvernement
président si pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement veut
bien levé la main merci pas d'opposition
il est adopté
le 250 de rectifier
tombe le 253 activités de même nous en
arrivions au 492 même que kidman
présente cet amendement il est défendu
mais je crois qu'on est revenu le roman
vendredi soir dans un cadre plus général
qui est notre souci en tout cas que
l'ensemble que les organisations
syndicales puissent être associée
pleinement dans les décisions de
l'évolution future puisque le seront au
sein de chacune des communes dans le
biais des ctp mais dans la construction
commune qui est bien un tour de table
avec l'ancien des l'ensemble pardon des
organisations syndicales représentatives
des fonctionnaires de la collectivité de
la fonction publique territoriale pardon
excusez moi merci cher collègue monsieur
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission
oui on a beaucoup débattu nous on ne
souhaite pas à la commission des lois
qu'il y ait une sorte de négociation
préalable à la coordination au sein de
la conférence territoriale et on a fait
observer qu à supposer même qu'un accord
de caractère contractuel ou
conventionnelle interviennent dans cette
conférence territoriale
il aurait pour produire des effets de
droit à faire l'objet de délibérations
dans chacune des collectivités qui de
par le conte le code général des
collectivités territoriales pour
délibérer ont besoin de recueillir
préalablement l'avis du comité technique
paritaire donc l'information et la
discussion nous paraît être
nécessairement réalisé dès lors que vous
déclinez la procédure dans son entier
donc on émet un avis défavorable
merci madame la ministre l'avis du
gouvernement oui je voudrais dire
combien le gouvernement est sensible et
attentif à la nécessité du dialogue
social je crois que ça a été dit dans
les jours qui précédaient
néanmoins comme le rapporteur vient de
l'exprimer ce n'est pas le lieu et qu'il
faudrait effectivement trouver un autre
lieu sur ces débats concernant les
personnels ou
organisation l'organisation des services
qui doit effectivement être débattue
mais dans un cadre qui n'est pas celui
là
merci madame ministre sur le 400 cadres
à nos explications de vote madame
kuperman pardon excusez moi brièvement
mais quoi faut pas nous faire dire ce
qu'on dit pas c'est qu'on demande pas
une consultation permanente et la
réunionite aiguë des uns et des autres
mais quand même on le dit ccc même
portée fortement parole et défenseurs de
la métropole
il va y avoir un pacte de cohérence
métropolitain qui va donc acté pour les
années qui suivent un certain nombre de
conséquences et d'évolution sur le
territoire au moins je veux bien que
tout soit facultatif et que chacun
puisse s'en remettre à ce qui va se
passer avec commune
mais si l'objectif c'est de fédérer tout
ça pour aller de l'avant et y compris
pour dépasser ce que j'ai entendu c'est
à dire des contraintes de chacune des
communes mais les unes à côté des autres
je trouve quand même surprenant qu'à
l'heure où on le gouvernement et puis
plus largement la majorité se font les
chantres du dialogue social y compris en
région rhône alpes où on est une terre
d'innovation sociale depuis de
nombreuses années on passe à côté à au
moment de la rédaction du pacte
territorial je parle pas de façon
systématique et immédiate d'avoir un
temps avec les organisations syndicales
au delà de ce qu'elles vont pouvoir
avoir au sein de chaque ctp de chacune
de leur commune mais d'avoir un projet
qui puisse les faire si c'est ce qui est
prévu qu'on peut l'inscrire dans la loi
sinon on ne serait pas dans la loi et on
en tire collectivement les conclusions
merci cher collègue monsieur collomb
pour explication de vote
je veux simplement remarquer que cela
sera fait par l'ensemble des organismes
paritaires à la fois de des communes et
en même temps de du du grand lyon de la
future métropole
donc les choses seront bien fait ainsi
et c'est je veux dire la loi il ya
consultation sur l'ensemble des choses
c'est déjà la loi actuelle ainsi chers
collègues je n'ai pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement
veuille bien levé
main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veuille bien levé la main l'amendement
n'est pas adopté l'amendement 493 et
défendu monsieur rapporteur quel est
l'avis de la commission
il est favorable aura pas de demande
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veut bien levé la
main merci pas d'opposition il est
adopté l'amendement 704 est présenté par
madani piette
merci monsieur le président il s'agit de
prévoir un conseil de développement
obligatoire qui réunit les représentants
des milieux économiques sociaux
culturels et associatifs puisqu'il n'y a
pas de texte qui prévoit la réunion
obligatoire ou la saisine obligatoire
d'un conseil de développement alors même
que le conseil de développement a fait
ses preuves partout la loire l'a rendu
possible il me paraît important donc que
pour lyon que nous présente comme étant
une métropole en pleine de développement
en plein développement pardon et bien il
est bien sûr un concept de développement
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur quel
est l'avis de la commission
cet amendement est satisfait par
l'article 27 bis du texte de la
commission qui crée un conseil de
développement auprès de la métropole de
lyon merci madame le ministre l'avis du
gouvernement l'avis du gouvernement
était favorable sur l'amendement mais
dès lors qu effectivement on le retrouve
à l'article 27 bis je crois que la
sagesse voudrait qu'il soit retiré de
madame il est retiré mon ami il est
retiré
nous en arrivons l'amendement 494
il est défendu madame kerman il est
défendu
monsieur rapporteur quel est l'avis de
la commission je reprends pas
l'argumentaire de tout à l'heure et je
me contente de dire que la commission
des lois a émis un avis défavorable
si monsieur rapporteur madame la
ministre mais ma vie même avis merci pas
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement veut
bien levé la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre eux veulent bien levé la
main l'amendement n'est pas adopté
et alors 12 amendements font l'objet
d'une discussion commune le 495 il est
défendu le 496 de même le 782 est
présenté par le ministre merci monsieur
président c'est un amendement qui vise à
rétablir certains éléments de la
rédaction du gouvernement sur les
compétences de la métropole de lyon tout
en maintenant les améliorations que la
commission des lois a apporté tout au
long de son examen
je voudrais préciser qu'à la différence
d'un établissement public de coopération
intercommunale à fiscalité propre
la métropole de lyon bénéficie d'une
clause de compétence générale qui rend
inutile certaines précisions qui ont été
apportées me semble-t-il par la
commission des définitions qui ont été
apportées pourrait créer à linverse des
ambiguïtés et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin d'un texte qui au
contraire et on l'a bien dit souvent
soit très clair introduire des
dispositions précisent aussi sur des
domaines qui sont pas confiés
particulièrement à une catégorie de
collectivités territoriales ne paraît
pas nécessaire en l'absence de position
les is législatives dans ces domaines
ceci relève de la clause de compétence
générale
voilà en ce qui concerne enfin la
participation au capital de certaines
sociétés
vous savez que nous avons un texte qui
va intervenir sur la croissance et
l'emploi et la promotion de l'égalité
des territoires et les régions la
mobilisation des régions dans lesquels
on trouvera une disposition de cette
nature donc le présente amendements que
nous nous que propose le gouvernement
rétablit donc des dispositions qui
permettent aux représentants de l'état
dans le département de délégués par
convention à la métropole qui ont fait
la demande
l'ensemble des compétences dans le
domaine du logement et de l'hébergement
les cinq compétences qui sont
l'attribution des aides à la pierre
r la gestion du contingent préfectoral
la gestion de la garantie du droit à un
logement décent et indépendant
le droit de réquisitionner des locaux
vacants voilà ce qu est l objet de cet
amendement auquel effectivement le
gouvernement tient pour bien que le
travail de la commission et été et nous
l'avons saluer chaque fois de grande
qualité
merci madame ministre l'amendement 355
et présentée par monsieur collomb mans
de réécriture sur donc quelque chose que
nous avions oublié dans l'écriture il se
trouve qu'un grand équipement et du du
culturel de la ville de lyon n'est pas
sur le territoire de la ville de lyon
est juste frontaliers et donc il s'agit
de réintégrer de manière à ce qu'il n'y
ait pas de confusion
merci chers collègues le 346 rectifiée
présentée par madame laborde
merci monsieur le président c'est à mon
nom était en réalité un amendement de
coordination anticipé avec d'autres
amendements numéro 3 145 déposé à
l'article 31 mai auquel la commission
des finances a opposé l'article 40 pour
une raison un peu obscur nous le
regrettons
le nouveau statut des métropoles prévoit
que celles ci seront compétentes pour
l'organisation des transports urbains
sur un périmètre de transport urbain et
par appel de compétences pour organiser
les transports scolaires le présent
amendement comme ceux que nous avons
dépenses déposé aux articles 30 et 31
vise à souligner que les transports
urbains ne sont pourtant qu'une
composante des transports dans les
espaces métropolitains qui inclut à la
fois des zones peu denses des zones
urbaines denses voir plusieurs pôles
urbains denses
il ne paraît donc pas souhaitable de
réduire le périmètre des métropoles à
des périmètres de transports urbains
péter eu en particulier compte tenu des
besoins couverts par les services
réguliers routiers et les services à la
demande en outre la mise en place d'un
pt eu à l'échelle d'un espace
métropolitain n'est pas sans
conséquences sur les entreprises de
transport
et notamment sur les entreprises
relevant des transports routiers
interurbains de voyageurs qui en l'état
actuel du texte verront leurs activités
encadrées par les dispositions de la
convention collective urbaine
l'impact en termes de coût et
l'organisation même du travail dans ce
gars sont en effet incompatible avec la
faible densité des territoires qui
relèvent actuellement de la compétence
transport routier du département
et pour lesquelles les entreprises
appliquent la convention collective
nationale des transports routiers et des
activités auxiliaires du transport
c'est la raison pour laquelle il
nécessaire d'étendre la compétence des
métropoles
ici celle de lyon à l'ensemble des
transports merci chers collègues le 347
rectifié my world
c'était deux bouts là il s'agit juste
entre guillemets pour le juste de
corriger une erreur de référence en
effet les articles l
1231 14 elle 1231 15 et el mil 231 16 du
code des transports n'existe pas encore
mais ont vocation à être créée par le
projet de loi de développement des
solidarités territoriales et de la
démocratie locale
d'où la nécessité d'adopter une approche
plus cohérente de la réforme de la
décentralisation
chers collègues 773 est présenté par
madame sy piette
oui c'est un amendement qui va être
terré en profite d'un autre texte qui va
être présenté plus tard par monsieur
fillol les ruelles où il est retiré
d'autres à 163 ch tout de suite au 703
qui vivent effectivement expressément
le syndicat mixte du sytral qui est
chargé de les transports collectifs
urbains revue effectivement on a
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui si on adopte
ce texte il n'y aura plus de mal de
transport en commun à lyon mais c'est
surtout un texte un amendement qui a
pour but d'attirer l'attention sur le
fait complètement étrange que ce
syndicat mixe soit au troisième degré
puisque ceux qui le gèrent ce sont des
élus d'éluder lui ça fait un peu
beaucoup pour une démocratie alors même
que le transport est au coeur même de ce
que les citoyens et citoyennes attendent
des services communautaires
c'est surtout un amendement d'appel le
350e 3 352 sont présentés par monsieur
collomb 53 il s'agit comme je les
mentionnaient ou tout à l'heure de bien
délimiter ce qui sera leva compétences
de la métropole et ceux qui sera
conservée par les communes
cet amendement vise précisé que le
comité
le conseil pardon local de sécurité de
prévention de la délinquance reste
d'ordre communal merci le 350 12 alors
le 350 2 il s'agit simplement
aujourd'hui dans la rédaction telle
qu'elle était faite
on a l'impression qu'on prendrait partie
de manière délibérée pour la délégation
de service public et pas pour la régie
on veut pouvoir regarder l'ensemble les
enjeux ouvert merci le 348 rectifiée
présentée par une anne laborde
oui merci monsieur le président par cet
amendement nous souhaitant donner à la
métropole de lyon la compétence
élaboration d'un périmètre des
transports métropolitains il vise donc
le même jeu objet que l'amendement
similaires déposées à l'article 31 pour
l'ensemble des métropoles la création de
la métropole ne doit donc pas impliquer
la création d'un pt mais reposer sur la
création d'un périmètre des transports
aux métropolitains la métropole aurait
ainsi
comme tâche d'élaborer un schéma de
transport distinguant les zones non
urbaines des zones urbaines stricto
sensu
cette solution offre le double avantage
de prendre en considération la diversité
des transports métropolitains desserte
de zones urbaines denses périurbaines et
rurales tout en évitant une inflation du
coût des transports publics dans l'air
métropolitaine alors que l'offre demeure
très constante si chers collègues enfin
le 361 est présentée par monsieur
collomb s'agit du problème de la
compétence logement
c'est quelque chose qui va revenir pour
20 kg et revenus ou qui va revenir
pardon pour l'ensemble des métropoles
nous nous ne pensons pas qu on puisse
effectivement transféré au métropole
qu'elle soit la métropole lyonnaise où
les autres l'ensemble des compétences et
en particulier le logement d'urgence
parce que celui ci est liée aux
politiques que mène le gouvernement et
donc qui ensuite pourrait mener un type
de politique est transféré la charge sur
les collectivités locales
je rappelle que par exemple pour donner
une idée des grandeurs pour ce qui
concerne l'aide à la pierre
les dotations en région sont le 45
millions pour l'hébergement d'urgence et
90 millions d'euros
donc on ne voudrait pas tout d'un coup
se voir transférer brusquement 90
millions d'euros qui sera à la charge de
la métropole merci cher collègue
monsieur rapporteur quel est l'avis de
la commission sur l'ensemble de ces
amendements monsieur le président
mesdames les ministres sur le 495 nous
avons un avis défavorable à l'amendement
substitue au transfert de plein droit
des compétences communales la référence
aux compétences aujourd'hui exercées par
la communauté urbaine le champ de ses
compétences est plus restreint
l'objectif assigné à l'article 20 t de
donner à la métropole les moyens de
mettre en oeuvre
le projet métropolitain voilà la raison
de notre avis défavorable pour le 496
l'amendement prévoit la consultation
pour avis des conseils municipaux avant
le transfert de plein droit à la
métropole des compétences communales
cette consultation est inopérante
puisque le transfert doit s'opérer par
la loi donc un avis défavorable pour le
780 deux du gouvernement et je le dis la
crainte révérencielle dans la voix ce
qui nous a gênés c'est effectivement
comme l'a dit monsieur collomb le blog
insécables parce que tout comme lui mes
collègues ne sont pas
hostile à l'opportunité éventuellement
sur le dalo d'une convention
particulière ont cité ce matin en
commission
l'exemple je pas moins d'une politique
en quartier en rue ou la collectivité
peut avoir intérêt à vérifier qu'au nom
de la mixité sociale
il n'ya pas alors que l'observatoire
national des zones urbaines sensibles a
plutôt tendance à dire le contraire
qu'il n'y a pas une surreprésentation de
personnes bénéficiaires du dalo dans les
quartiers en question donc on n'exclut
pas des conventions particulières ce qui
a coincé la commission c'est le
caractère insécables c'est-à-dire qui
laisse présumer un transfert certains
ont même dit que l'état se défausser sur
les métropoles c'est affreusement
caricatural à mesa a été prononcé donc
pour le reste le raisonnement et j'avais
votre rapporteur il avait pris aussi
hier pour illustrer la compétence
générale
le raisonnement que madame la ministre a
tenu à toute sa pertinence
maintenant vous comprenez bien c'est le
sens de la rédaction qui est ici proposé
à l'heure où précisément et à
un impact territorial à mettre en oeuvre
les élus ont préféré qui est quand même
une énumération préciser je dirais
énuméra tiff justement enfin une liste
qui énumère les compétences parce qu'ils
ont peur que la présomption soit
autrement systématiquement de laisser
penser que les communes sont privés de
ces compétences donc je reconnais la
pertinence du raisonnement
pourtant pour des raisons psychologiques
qui vise à rassurer les communes sur la
sur ce qu'elle conserve comme compétente
et était préféré la rédaction d'une
liste même si je reconnais que elle
n'allait pas de soi endroit madame je le
reconnai volontier
j'ai moi-même eu pris votre exemple hier
s'agissant de la différence entre un
opci et une collectivité territoriale
même sweat generis comme dit le texte
donc voilà pour l'amendement du
gouvernement ou à mon grand regret on a
donc un avis défavorable mais j'ai voulu
j'avais un petit doute monsieur non non
je mets un petit doute on peut être
défavorable et mettre les formes
monsieur absolument
sur l'amendement 355
l'amendement précise les modalités
entourant le transfert à la métropole
d'équipements culturels et sportifs des
communes préexistantes cette disposition
adoptée en commission et subit est
superflu pour pensons-nous puisque la
compétence transférée inclus par sa
généralité les équipements existants
donc on a émis un avis favorable pour ce
qui est de l'amendement de monsieur méar
à l'article 20 ans il a été dit en
commission et je m'en remets à vous
chère madame
il a été dit que plutôt que d'utiliser
mobilité urbaine
plusieurs commissaires ont dit que le
terme qui était préférable c'était
supprimer le bon urbaine et donc de
préférer mobilité donc si vous acceptiez
est seulement à cette condition de
rectifier l'amendement il pourrait être
la vie pourrait être favorable
accepter ça devient le rectifier miss
sur le 347 l'amendement supprime les
références aux articles que propose de
créer le projet de loi développement des
solidarités territoriales numéro 4 197
or il n'est pas encore inscrit à l'ordre
du jour il apparaît toujours hasardeuses
et en tous les cas de mauvaise pratique
législative que de faire référence à des
articles aujourd'hui inexistants quoi
qui ne sont pas encore dans le droit
positif pour cette raison nous nous vous
suggérons des maîtres nous avons émis un
avis favorable à l'amendement
puisque monsieur mézard semble tout à
fait dans son droit de ne pas anticiper
sur un droit qui n'est pas encore
positive si je veux dire pour
l'amendement 703 de madame lipietz la
métropole de lions termes de l'article
20 sera substitué de plein droit pour
les compétences communales obligatoire
et les compétences départementales aux
syndicats de communes ou syndicats
mixtes dans le périmètre est identique
au sien ou inclus dans le sien elle sera
substituée aux communes de son périmètre
dans les syndicats dans le périmètre est
partiellement un cul dans le sien
l'amendement propose d'unifier la
compétence transports de la métropole au
sein d'un même organisme
il ne nous semble pas à la commission
des lois pertinent de modifier
brutalement par la loi l'organisation
actuelle qu implique d'autres
collectivités que les communes de son
périmètre
l'amendement a beau tirer a désorganisé
les transports dans l'ensemble de la
zone
raison pour laquelle nous avons préféré
émettre un avis défavorable
il me reste 3 153 c'est ça c'est ça soit
153 l'amendement vise à supprimer le
transfert à la métropole de la
compétence communale en matière de
dispositifs locaux de prévention de la
délinquance
aujourd'hui il s'agit là d'une
compétence de la communauté urbaine
cependant dans le cadre du pacte de
cohérence mais
polythène la métropole pourra déléguer
cette compétence aux communes de son
périmètre la commission des lois on a
beaucoup débattu
moi je comprends parfaitement que les
conseils locaux et les maires le demande
j'ai un monsieur bret qui est venu en
audition en fait un élément essentiel de
la concertation avec sa population est
naturellement le suis néanmoins on
souhaite que même ne pas enlever la
possibilité comme la loi d'ailleurs le
prévoit dans le statut des communautés
urbaines de pouvoir de temps en temps
réunir à l'échelle communautaire eu un
conseil communautaire de prévention de
la délinquance parce que on a résonné en
disant que des problématiques comme
celle par exemple de la sécurité dans
les transports ne peuvent être
pertinemment posé qu'à cette échelle là
donc on émet un avis favorable
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance si
vous souhaitez la revoir ou en savoir
plus sur cette question de la
décentralisation notre site internet
publicsenat.fr bonne journée à tous